on va parler de la France insoumise
Michael et Raphaël d'abord un point avec
vous Audrey puisque le fonctionnement de
la France insoumise est jugé obscure
gazeux par des voies en interne et du
coup ça donne lieu à des tensions au
sein du mouvement oui parce que certains
parlent même d'un manque de démocratie
au sein de la France insoumise alors il
faut rappeler que ce n'est pas un parti
c'est un mouvement pas de carte pas de
cotisation on peut adhérer en quelques
clics sur Internet 370
000 personnes l'aurait déjà fait mais
finalement c'est vrai qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment combien sont réellement
insoumis alors quand on cherche qui
décide là ça devient très compliqué
c'est ce que révèle Le Parisien il y a
une association LFI c'est elle qui
valide les décisions qui tient le
porte-monnaie elle tient les contes et
elle compte justement trois membres
manuels Bompard le président qui est
coordinateur national du Mouvement je
vais y revenir c'est le bras droit de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Mathilde panot la
secrétaire patronne des insoumis à
l'Assemblée et Maxime charpentier le
trésorier un visage inconnu et alors
pour l'anecdote Raquel Garrido insoumise
de la première heure à essayer d'y AD
cette association elle a envoyé sa
candidature elle n'a toujours pas eu de
réponse c'était il y a un petit moment
on comprend donc que c'est très
verrouillé est-ce qu'il y a la
coordinaire alors ça il y a aussi la
coordination des espaces ça peut vous
expliquer ça alors la coordination des
espaces est chargée notamment
d'organiser les événements la
communication s'il y a un meeting c'est
elle qui s'en occupe on trouve des
proches de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Mathilde
panot toujours Manon Aubry Louis Boyard
aussi qu'on connaît à l'intérieur plus
restreint il y a un conseil politique
dont manuel bon par encore lui a pris la
tête lors d'un vote à l'unanimité le
problème c'est que tout le monde a voté
pour lui mais tout le monde n'était pas
invité et notamment ceux qui critiquent
le fonctionnement nébuleux voire
anti-démocratique ce sont leurs mots de
la France insoumise clémentinottin
Alexis Corbière qu'on voit à l'image
Raquel Garrido ça a donné lieu à une
scission j'en veux pour preuve une vidéo
tournée il y a une semaine que je vais
vous montrer ces trois-là sont en
meeting à Bobigny contre la réforme des
retraites je sais pas si on peut voir
oui on voit la vidéo accompagnée de
François Ruffin et ils organ ce meeting
sans avoir reçu d’être financière du
parti on leur a même refusé mais c'est
pas tout à ce moment là Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est en meeting aussi lui à
Montpellier toujours sur le sujet de la
réforme des retraites on voit vraiment
qu'il y a scission alors Oriane tout à
l'heure vous lui avez posé la question
manuel bon parquet était votre invité
vous lui avez demandé poser une question
justement sur ce fonctionnement un peu
gazeux sur les critiques en interne on
va écouter sa réponse
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire en
fonctionnement moins gazeux le
fonctionnement de la France insoumise
c'est un fonctionnement ouvert sous la
forme d'un mouvement politique et ça
restera comme ça parce que ça a été
constitué comme ça et que les gens qui
l'ont rejoint ils sont attachés à ça
c'est pas un mouvement sur lequel
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à la main mise
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire avoir la
main mise est-ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
exerce une forme d'autorité
intellectuelle morale oui pourquoi parce
que il a fait
22% des voix la dernière élection
présidentielle qu'il a été le meilleur
représentant possible pour le programme
que l'on défend et quand vous rejoignez
une formation politique vous le faites
plutôt avec l'objectif de faire 22 % que
1%. voilà pour le fonctionnement un peu
malgré les extras il y a un fou il y a
un problème de démocratie interne à la
France insoumise c'est en tout cas ce
qu'on soulevait plusieurs personnalités
du mouvement si on refait un peu
l'historique on sait qu'il y a des gens
par exemple Clémentine Autain qui avait
mis le problème sur la table déjà depuis
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années là
c'est vrai que finalement à l'occasion
de va réorganisation de de la direction
qui a eu lieu à la fin de l'année
dernière ces voix sont exprimées de
façon beaucoup plus directe beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus ouvertes et en
pointant en tout cas ce qui de leur
point de vue était un manque de
démocratie et surtout en fait un manque
d'implication des militants dans les
décisions qui engageaient le mouvement
stratégique électoral tactique etc
en tout cas il semble là maintenant
depuis encore plus depuis qu'on est
passé dans la bataille contre la réforme
de retraite que cette manche en interne
elle a été perdue par ceux qui
défendaient une autre organisation
puisqu'il semble aujourd'hui en tout cas
pas avoir trouvé de majorité pour faire
avancer leur leurs idées au sein du
mouvement en tout cas le débat a
continué d'exister ça c'est sûr c'est un
fonctionnement trop gazeux comme le
dénonce notamment Clément
pas démocratie interne une travée royale
contrôle total de trois personnes et
purge quand on n'est pas d'accord c'est
un parti autocratique extrêmement
classique que l'on connaît dans d'autres
pays et qui ont prouvé leur efficacité
dans des pays où la démocratie n'a pas
lieu d'être parce qu'il y a une volonté
d'avoir toujours la main mise de la part
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est ça qui
explique ce fonctionnement qui perdure à
la France une philosophie politique
puisque lui il est contre la
social-démocratie ils prêtent il prône
depuis des années le fait qu'il faut
justement faire table rase de ces
institutions là de manière à pouvoir
instaurer un système
issu d'une révolution et qui débouchant
sur une nouvelle république
fondée sur vers une démarche
conflictuelle permanente d'où justement
la stratégie adoptée à l'Assemblée à la
demande de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour se
débat des retraites et des bouchons sur
une mise en tension de la société en
permanence donc tout cela pas
correspond à la philosophie politique de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et lorsqu'on a vu ses
compagnons de route qui
pompe ou laisser tous un peu entendre
qu'il fallait évoluer qu'il faudrait
faire évoluer la culture politique
éventuellement se rapprocher d'une
logique de consensus ils ont été purgés
ils ont été dégagés parce que le parti
avance on sait plus grand c'est une
grande tradition ça correspond une
philosophie politique en fait je pense
quand même question on remet les choses
en perspective même des gens que j'ai
cité Clémentine Notin mais même elle a
dit que l'organisation qui a été celle
du mouvement depuis sa création de fin
2016 début 2017 avait eu son intérêt et
avait eu son efficacité à un moment ce
que les personnalités qui sont opposées
à la nouvelle direction un nouvel
organisation 10 et que maintenant il est
il est temps de passer à une nouvelle
étape après l'élection de présidentielle
de 2022 et ce qui avait pu constituer un
avantage dans les campagnes électorales
avant aujourd'hui était de leur point de
vue en tout cas davantage un frein donc
finalement voilà le débat peut-être pas
aussi Manic rien que ça simplement voilà
il y a beaucoup de gens qui se disent
peut-être que maintenant on est moins
nécessité dans une espèce de forme de
voilà de d'organisation un peu je dirais
pas militaire mais il y avait un peu cet
esprit vu qu'il y a pas d'échéance
électorales en tout cas dans les mois à
venir et que donc c'était peut-être le
moment de poser les bases du nouvel
organisation est-ce qu'il y a un
problème Mélenchon est-ce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il fait plus de mal que de
bien à la France insoumise et à la nuque
c'est ce qu'on interne certains pensent
aujourd'hui sans vouloir vraiment le
l'assumer ou l'avouer mais un Ruffin le
pense des même les aujourd'hui et les
garridos et et Corbières le pense qu'ils
façon il a fait aussi son temps vous
savez à un moment donné le leader qui a
qui a été la locomotive devient aussi
un boulet c'est une démarche de
l'histoire on l'a vu dans d'autres
parties et je pense que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est frappé par cette cette
période là et par cette démarche
d'autant plus que l'enjeu effectivement
et d'ailleurs c'est même enfin qu'il
avait dit l'enjeu aujourd'hui depuis
l'arrivée à l'Assemblée nationale et de
montrer la capacité à produire de la
politique publique à pouvoir être
apporté vraiment ce que veulent des
politiques qui peuvent aider les
Français et jusqu'à présent c'est un peu
compliqué quand même pour pour la
nupaise en tout cas pour la France
insoumise pardon de de pouvoir le
prouver là ils ont pas réussi à passer à
faire beaucoup avancer leurs idées
durant ce débat à part la capacité à
pouvoir se faire entendre et à pouvoir
créer de la conflictualité et d'ailleurs
c'était une des raisons et les termes
employés par aussi crémantinopa dans son
texte cet été c'était de dénoncer
l'opacité de remettre en question le
rapport à la conflictualité d'être
capable d'être beaucoup plus dans le
dans la recherche de consensus
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Sandrine Rousseau sur
notre plateau lundi disait qu'il fallait
un acte 2 de la nuit plus clair plus
démocratique
je pense qu'elle faisait super civique
nous parlons particulièrement référence
à la journée de jeudi dernier où il y a
effectivement ce tweet contre enfin qui
dénonçait leur retrait des amendements
du Parti communiste et puis aussi ces
déclarations de la manifestation qui
disait que la multiplication des
journées d'action de mobilisation avait
peut-être atteint ses limites
ponctuellement oui il y a des députés de
la nupaise qui ont pu penser que ces
sorties là
précisément avait nuit au débat ou en
tout cas la stratégie du groupe à
l'Assemblée
il n'empêche que si on est tout à fait
honnête sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y
aurait pas de nups aujourd'hui donc je
pense que le débat il est il est moins
là-dessus que sur disons que en quittant
l'Assemblée nationale et en prenant des
nouvelles fonctions de président de
l'Institut La Boétie la Fondation qu'il
préside aujourd'hui il a donné le
sentiment à beaucoup de gens pas de
quitter la vie politique mais de faire
un pas côté ou de se mettre en retrait
quel que soit la façon dont on a
interprété et il se trouve qu'on voit
bien que plusieurs mois après après il
reste de toute manière son nombre planes
autour des débats que ça soit la France
insoumise ou la nupaise donc il y a
aussi beaucoup de gens qui savent pas
vraiment à quoi s'en tenir avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui justement parce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est plus député
mais quand il y a eu ce tweet finalement
une partie des débats qui était censé
être consacré à la réforme des retraites
a eu lieu autour du tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est l'exécutif qui a
commencé à le mettre sur la table et
puis ça s'est en venimeux avec les
échanges avec Manuel Bompard donc on
voit que même si il n'est plus à
l'Assemblée il n'est plus député il est
toujours finalement au Palais Bourbon
oui mais c'était l'enjeu depuis le début
de la législature à partir du moment où
il avait décidé de ne plus se
représenter à l'Assemblée le problème de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'était son existence
par rapport à son au sein de son
mouvement et par rapport à à l'opinion
et par rapport donc à l'exécutif donc il
a fait ça exactement à des saints
sachant pertinemment que tout le monde
reprendrait son son propos et qu'il
organiserait le débat autour de lui ce
qui fait évidemment grincer des dents
aussi en interne et ce qui précipite ce
vers quoi on va aller c'est à dire je
dirais la le désossement et le
démantèlement de la nupestre qui est un
son est un a été grâce à son je dirais
son sa présence d'esprit son génie
politique a une mise en cartel
électorale mais qui n'a pas vocation
être un mouvement
bah oui c'est déjà le c'est déjà le cas
elle a une espérance de vie très courte
la nuque alors
la ville la nuque est compliquée elle
est faite de soubresaut d'aller retour
après voilà c'est toujours un peu
compliqué de décréter le désossement ou
la mort de la nuque en tout cas de
donner une date parce qu'on a dit ça
déjà depuis les législatives et on voit
bien que aujourd'hui ça existe toujours
la question c'est c'est quoi la nuque en
fait finalement pour beaucoup de gens
c'est simplement une alliance
strictement parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale on voit que Manuel Montard et
d'autres gens à la France insoumise
pensent ça comme quelque chose qui doit
aussi concerner les militants la société
civile le Parlement de la Nupe c'est
quelque chose de très important pour
elle les filles d'un peu moins important
pour les autres parties partenaires mais
en tout cas voilà la vraie question
c'est est-ce que ça peut continuer à
être une coalition électorale je pense
pas qu'au Parlement la nu pendant
qu'elle en tant que tel va disparaître
en tout cas on voit bien que les groupes
même s'ils sont opposés à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ils ont besoin de cette
alliance à l'Assemblée en revanche aller
plus loin et notamment pour des
candidatures en commun ça c'est vraiment
un sujet qui reste encore en débat
est-ce que ce que redemande de Manuel
Bompard ce matin chez nous il a dit
qu'il voulait des candidatures communes
au sénatorial aux européennes même s'il
est bien conscient que les écologistes
n'en veulent pas c'est justement ce qui
sera le point le point crucial et la
vérité des prises ce sera les ce sont
les élections européennes même si
effectivement les soubresauts les
tensions et la volonté de porter ça à
bout de bras avec des déclarations plus
ou moins sincères va continuer aux
élections européennes il y aura des
listes séparées et ce sera la fin de la
Nuxe on va parler des syndicats dans
quelques instants est-ce que ce qui
s'est passé avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
fait que cet article 7 n'est pas été
examiné ça crée une fracture entre la
France insoumise et le monde syndical en
tout cas du point de vue des partenaires
particulièrement les socialistes les
écologistes les communistes
il y a eu cette parmi les députés à un
certain sentiment de gâchis en fait de
voir Laurent Berger mais aussi Philippe
Martinez critiquée prendre du temps de
parole pour critiquer cette stratégie à
la pardon à la à l'Assemblée nationale
là où beaucoup se disaient bon vraiment
voilà cette année on devrait être tous
unis contre le gouvernement et donc
on devrait aider les syndicats et de
voir les syndicats manifestement pointés
du doigt et dénoncer de cette stratégie
c'est pas forcément la bonne façon de
faire ceci dit il y a entre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et les centrales syndicales
depuis déjà plusieurs années je dirais
une incompréhension mais même de toute
façon ils sont pas d'accord sur la façon
de faire c'est à dire que pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a une partie de la France
insoumise
les manifestations à l'ancienne la
mobilisation syndicale elle est
nécessaire elle est utile mais eux
pensent vraiment que il faut autre chose
aussi par exemple les manifestations le
week-end et il pense que tout est
complémentaire là où le reste de la
gauche est peut-être dans une posture un
peu plus traditionnelle et se disent
nous on doit être en soutien du
mouvement syndical et on doit en tout
cas leur donner les rênes et surtout pas
donner l'impression
de vouloir mener notre propre stratégie
de cette contestation contre la réforme
des retraites Emmanuel Macron était à
Rungis à l'aube hier à la rencontre de
la France qui travaille et qui se lève
tôt c'était le message il en a profité
pour défendre sa réforme des retraites
mais l'Inter syndicale ne cède pas il y
a un effet
comme une mise en jambe avant le salon
de l'agriculture samedi Emmanuel Macron
à la rencontre de la France qui se lève
tôt dès 5h hier c'est un message de
reconnaissance d'abord devant toutes
celles et ceux qui permettent au pays de
tourner de vivre une opportunité pour
lui de réinvestir la valeur travail
devant les caméras au cours de sa
déambulation le président est
régulièrement
interpellés qui sont travaillés dans les
citations comme ça au niveau des
recettes l'occasion pour lui de défendre
la réforme sur le terrain oui il faut
travailler un peu plus longtemps en
moyenne tous parce que sinon on pourra
pas bien financer nos retraites devant
les professionnels Emmanuel Macron
justifie le report de l'âge légal comme
une mesure de bon sens
c'est un mensonge qui rassure je préfère
la vérité qui fâche et donc oui nous
vivons plus âgés oui nous avons un
système par répartition qui est le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
été préservés une référence pas vraiment
du goût de l'interdydical les 8
principes à l'organisation se sont
réunis le soir même aujourd'hui le bon
sens c'est lui qui devrait l'avoir et
c'est lui qui devrait écouter
effectivement ce qui se passe dans la
France aujourd'hui des territoires les
centrales se donnent un objectif faire
de la mobilisation du 7 mars la plus
forte depuis le début de la contestation
l'Inter syndicale réaffirme sa
détermination pour mettre la France à
l'arrêt plusieurs secteurs comme la RATP
ou les raffineries ont déjà annoncé leur
intention de se lancer dans des grèves
reconductibles
est-ce que c'était bien joué
politiquement Michael cette sortie hier
d'Emmanuel Macron et cette phrase d'en
appeler au bon sens des Français sur la
réforme des retraites c'était une
gestion de crise parce qu'en fait
Emmanuel Macron l'a fait pour une seule
raison il a lu très attentivement mais
les études et les Verbatim de ceux qui
sont plutôt du côté de Marine Le Pen et
qui considère qu'il s'ouvre un manque de
reconnaissance c'est sa première phrase
quand il arrive en disant c'est pour une
reconnaissance c'est pour reconnaître
les gens et il sait très bien que de ce
point de vue là il y a une un déficit
sur le volet social sur le volet de la
reconnaissance et en particulier sur ces
fameux travailleurs de la deuxième ligne
qu'il avait encensé à l'époque du covid
et qui ont un sentiment d'être
maintenant abandonné donc il fait cette
sortie pour cela et ensuite pour pouvoir
faire la pelle à aux entreprises de
aider en particulier énergétique dans
l'énergie de pouvoir donc aider les
Français c'est pour cette raison là qui
fait ça il pouvait pas le faire au salon
de l'agriculture parce qu'il il va être
happé par d'autres sujets et son
discours sera pas audit donc il fallait
qu'il vienne pour compenser le déficit
qu'il a et qui lui retransmit
régulièrement dans sa relation avec les
Français en particulier avec les
Français justement de classe beaucoup
plus populaires qui sont et qui saute en
train de se tourner vers Marine Le Pen
c'est absolument que très clairement
selon les études et on le voit et c'est
la grande crainte de de l'Elysée
justement dans la série voilà vers 2027
de ce qui de ce qui se prépare je pense
qu'il y avait aussi une demande de la
part de son camp de le voir peut-être
monter un peu plus en première ligne
expliquer finalement le fond de cette
réforme que lui a voulu puisqu'il
l'avait suspendu en 2019 a décidé de la
réintroduire et donc il y avait aussi
peut-être du point de vue de ceux qui à
l'Assemblée ont tenu voilà difficilement
pendant deux semaines contre tous les
opposants à cette réforme de voir le
chef de l'État finalement redire
pourquoi nécessaire de son point de vue
et quel était le sens de cette réforme
et effectivement faire cet effort de
pédagogie qui doit continuer à être fait
de leur point de vue puisqu'on voit bien
que jusqu'au 7 mars
cette histoire est loin d'être fini quoi
et c'est aussi un message pour son camp
est-ce qu'il a trop laissé des abeilles
borne et les députés montré au front
est-ce qu'il est trop resté en arrière
sur cette réforme qui est au cœur des
préoccupations des Français je crois que
c'est un message pour la droite parce
que il a il a fait une scénographie
sarkozienne il a il a utilisé les mêmes
mots de la France qui était
il a fait exactement la même posture que
en fait à contretemps quand Nicolas
Sarkozy au début de la réforme des
régimes spéciaux de la SNCF va voir les
cheminots se met devant les cheminots et
leur dit c'est pas la rue qui va
m'imposer quoi que ce soit
Nicolas Sarkozy a expliqué Emmanuel
Macron qu'il aurait dû le faire depuis
le début là il le fait mais avec retard
et il vient effectivement dire je viens
assumer quelque chose même si ça fâche
et je m'appelle à votre bon sens c'est
très tard c'est tardif mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la scénographie
est totalement je dirais quasi je veux
dire inspirer par une scénographie qui
justement parle à la droite parce qu'en
ce moment d'autres enjeux sont en train
de se mettre en place puisqu'il y a on
sait un dialogue en tout cas une
tentative nouvelle de Nicolas Sarkozy de
faire d'amener Emmanuel Macron à un
accord officiel avec la droite après la
réforme des retraites pour pouvoir
changer la donne politique après
depuis l'élection d'eriki c'est à
nouveau d'actualité nicolas Sarkozy
reçoit beaucoup de monde et explique
après après les retraites il faudra
faire le rassemblement et donc c'est ce
qui le vend entre guillemets à Madame
Macron qui cherche aussi une sortie
vraisemblablement sur un chantier
institutionnel on verra comment ça se
passera mais en tout cas il y a il y a
ce travail qui se fait donc c'est aussi
cette sortie et cette scénographie je
dirais d'Emmanuel Macron vient aussi
envoyer tous ces messages à la partie de
la classe politique Raphaël
à droite c'est très bien dit je veux pas
revenir dessus mais on parlait de
François Ruffin tout à l'heure qui
insiste lui aussi par exemple qui est
quelqu'un je pense qui a gagné des
points dans cette bataille des retraites
en tout cas l'assemblée lui aussi et sur
ce créneau la France qui se lève tôt la
France du travail etc donc il y a aussi
un enjeu à parler à cette France là
puisqu'on voit bien qu'il y a en tout
cas sur cette réforme une
incompréhension entre une partie des
surtout enfin elle est très claire sur
les actifs ou concrètement donc il y a
effectivement aussi un enjeu à occuper
ce terrain même si c'est vrai que le
rassemblement national peut-être dans
l'opinion à un coup voir deux coups
d'avance mais on voit bien qu'en tout
cas du côté d'une partie de la gauche il
y a la volonté de reconquérir cette
électorat ou en tout cas de regagner des
points dans l'opinion de ce point de vue
là effectivement aller à la rencontre de
cette France là ça peut être tout sauf
accessoire et pas sur le bon sens elle a
fait réagir à l'intersyndical on les a
entendus qui réaffirme sa volonté de
bloquer le pays le 7 mars est-ce que ça
peut relancer le mouvement de dire j'en
appelle au bon sens des Français ça peut
apparaître comme une forme de
déconnexion de la part du Président je
pense que de toute façon au point où on
en était les positions sont tellement
antagonistes que est-ce que finalement
ça va aggraver ou pas je pense que voilà
à partir du moment où la date du 7 mars
a été fixé maintenant on est simplement
dans une espèce de de construction de
monter en puissance parce que voilà
c'est une chose d'agiter cette date mais
il va falloir cette journée d'action
soit vraiment réussi parce que ça va
être une date extrêmement cruciale on
parle de bloquer le pays de payer à
l'arrêt forcément on a mis la barre très
haut du côté des syndicats maintenant
voilà il s'agit de rassembler le plus
possible pour pas rater cette date c'est
une journée au risque politiquement pour
l'exécutif sur cette mars beaucoup plus
pour les syndicats que pour l'exécutif
parce qu'effectivement le l'objectif
d'abord sera très difficile d'évaluer si
la France a été à l'arrêt ou pas d'abord
ce terme et montre bien que il y a pas
il y a pas d'accord entre les syndicats
c'est un terme neutre qui qui ne veut
pas dire grand chose en réalité mais qui
montre surtout qu'il y avait pas de il y
a des divergences stratégiques déjà sur
est-ce qu'il faut continuer un mouvement
de grève perlée est-ce qu'il faut
revenir sur des aller sur du
reconductibles ce qu'il faut faire un
blocage à l'ancienne ils ont trouvé ce
terme qui veut pas dire grand chose
parce qu'il sera extrêmement difficile à
mesurer ça veut dire quoi la France à
l'arrêt et pour 24 heures ça servirait à
quoi en plus donc ils sont maintenant un
point de vérité d'autant plus qu'ils ont
la conscience d'avoir beaucoup gagné
regagner dans ce dans ce mouvement
depuis les gilets jaunes ils ont réussi
à mobiliser très fortement et au-delà
même de leurs abonnés je dirais ils ont
maintenu des manifestations sans
débordement et sans violence et c'est
aussi une des raisons de la divergence
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui lui une fois
de plus est pour la conflictualité à
organiser à l'Assemblée une une logique
d'interpellation très forte et ça n'a
pas plu au syndicat parce que eux disent
nous avons réussi à démontrer qu'on peut
contrer cette cette réforme de manière
je dirais peut-être plus classique plus
plus calme alors que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui en plus un filtre aussi beaucoup les
syndicats c'est aussi les raisons de
colère lui et sur notre voie un dernier
mot
et puis pour revenir à ce que vous
disiez c'est vrai que si on va par
exemple dans les manifestations de la
France insoumise on remarquera qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de syndicalistes je
pense notamment aux manifestations
contre la vie chère qui avait eu à la
rentrée à l'automne dernier donc
finalement oui chez les syndicats il y a
aussi cette connaissance du fait que le
discours de la France insoumise et
surtout le fait qu'ils aient été pendant
la dernière législature le principal
groupe principal opposition de gauche
certaines formes de production qui opère
ici mais vraiment beaucoup plus depuis
la base on voit quand même effectivement
que beaucoup de logique se rencontrent
et j'ajouterai un dernier point c'est
vrai que la France à l'arrêt c'est assez
vague mais ça aura aussi
l'avantage de permettre au syndicat de
dire voyons on a mis la France à l'arrêt
même si ça signifie pour beaucoup de
travailleurs juste mettre la clé sous la
porte pendant deux ou trois heures
évidemment de ce mouvement regarde
[Musique]